it's hard to say to somebody be creative
right of course it's like say somebody
be a great
football player and then you'll be in
the world cup well no kidding
but you know how and the answer is you
have to practice
you've got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
[Music]
the business summit gary vaynerchuk
[Music]
brand minds live
hey gary nice to see you man welcome to
brand minds
i've seen you three years ago when i met
you and you inspired me to
to create content for for entrepreneurs
and so
so thank you man and welcome back
thank you for having me i'm so honored
to be here and congratulations in
pulling off this incredible virtual
event
thank you very much for everything you
are doing for for this event and for uh
for the entire entrepreneurial community
in the
in the world so we'll have 55 minutes of
questions
and uh i have 15 to 20 questions for you
that will squeeze a lot of value from
you for our excited audience they waited
for you the whole day you are the
head of the line for today this is the
last meeting
so i will read them one by one to be
specific and explicit so
if you are ready we can start i'm ready
okay cool so let's start with business
and i will keep some personal questions
at the end first question in business
area
what is the main strategy to leverage
the business growth in
covid 19 crisis
so i think the first thing that people
have to look at is being self-aware
and really understanding what they can
or cannot accomplish during this time
obviously if you're a restaurant
or a concert venue or something of that
nature it's going to be very difficult
for you to
salvage the situation on the flip side
if you're a restaurant that can go to
local delivery
or a conference that can go to digital
and virtual
you can and so i think the biggest thing
is to not dwell about
what has happened and what you cannot do
and really really really focus on what
you can do
and what you can do about it and so for
me
um what is your product and service how
has it
actually been affected by covid and how
do you
then take advantage of the new world we
live in whether that's
creating a direct to consumer e-commerce
situation whether that is creating a new
product
that services the market there there's
been clothing brands
that have started manufacturing masks so
to me it's about adjusting to the
reality
and i noticed from a lot of
entrepreneurs a lot of them have
cried about the situation and the
problem is that doesn't change the
situation so
self-awareness and and innovation are
really the two pillars
that are going to help people and then
and then the other thing
is and i'm sure we'll get into questions
around this what is your content and
media strategy for the internet
at this time true but you know
innovation at some point
could be uh in a way disturbing because
even this event
no one's seen a setup like this it's
like you
it's like it's been recorded it's it's
you know it's so
so live and so rich of
information that is you know in in this
period
it can be uh in a way uh difficult for
people to understand the
the 10 steps in innovation that you are
doing because
that's the thing that is happening right
here in brandmine so uh
what about this what about if this
crisis
and this covid19 uh generate maybe
a leap of innovation that is too much
for uh for the consumer
the consumer is king so
you know i don't even you know and i
appreciate your reaction
i don't i'm blown away by people
who try to fight against the consumer
you know i see people innovate i've been
in you know silicon valley
startup social media digital media
for a very long time and everybody was
always
innovating around me and
when i watched entrepreneurs get mad at
the customer
for not adopting i'll give you a good
example qr codes
i had so many entrepreneurs seven eight
years ago working on qr code
innovation and when they were struggling
after two years
they were blaming the customer these
idiots they don't know what to do with
it they don't get how good it is
and i said that is the most asinine way
to think about a problem in business
the customer is always right is true you
you know
if to your point if we over innovate
during this time um
if people overreact to covet and say oh
my god
everyone's nobody's going into the
office ever again
you know we have to make everything
virtual i'm going to bet my whole life
on just
just virtual they're going to lose
because it's going to be a mix
it's going to be a mix and so you know
for me
it you know that's why i laughed when
you when you said that you know like
there's only the customer to me sure and
keeping in mind that we are passing
through this period with cov19
what are the top three qualities of an
entrepreneur now
in this area that we are just starting
you know i i think the characteristics
are the
top three characteristics always i
actually think we're starting to see the
other side of entrepreneurship now
you know over the last decade it's been
so easy and people forgot
so much money so such great economies
so much money being printed so much
money being deployed i think people lost
their way
i think people got confused and so for
me
um this is a game of very
simple real
long-term truths for example an
entrepreneur is somebody who looked at
covet and coronavirus
and and went immediately into action
to address whatever vulnerabilities she
or he had
you know an entrepreneur was really
tested during this time
this was you know a very real thing and
most people just have been dealing with
rosy colored
glasses and situations so you know
entrepreneur is always ready to be the
last line of defense she is
and he is somebody that is always ready
to innovate
um you know so to me it's
they're a firefighter is number one
like a firefighter in real life they're
always ready to
they could be sleeping and they have to
address something sure number two
they're an innovator
they're they're looking at the situation
and they're saying this is not working
anymore let me change it i'm gonna sell
this
or i'm gonna change my service and do
that and number three
i think that they are one that can
communicate
with their audience and with more
importantly the people that work for
them
they're truly a leader because an
entrepreneurial business
will never survive because the ideas are
too crazy
the risk is too high if you're not
really
a great communicator people won't
jump on board and support you and take
that risk along with you
and so i think number three they're a
communications leader
firefighter innovator communications
leader
that's cool and i think we've had a lot
of fake entrepreneurs in the last
five to seven years because the economy
was growing
and now we will see who's really
entrepreneur or who's uh maybe a
self-employed in herself
in his company so last question about
kovid uh
and then we go hold on one second i have
to i have to give a shout out
to blau matthias who just tweeted at me
a nice picture of me on the screen
and said great that he's happy to see me
here big shout out
mate elektra uh so for everybody who's
watching right now since we are live
feel free to take photos and and tweet
at me it's gary v-e-e
and it adds to the energy i like the
energy of the room so let's
let's i'm innovating right now my friend
right i
i have a big public speaking career
because i love interaction with the
crowd
thank god you're here because i've done
a couple where i'm just speaking
and it's not the same because i'm not
getting the feedback
you responding in laughter to my
laughter
of that first question about the or
second question about customers that
helped me
right now you know matthias
tweeting the picture and saying what
he's thinking about what i'm saying
that's helping me
and and so knowing that i'll be doing a
lot more virtual the rest of my life
everybody is watching please hit me up
on twitter right now with a screenshot
and an observation
it will add to the nuance keep going
cool
so last question about kovid uh is this
crisis affected your business
and if so in any way and how how did you
reacted
it affects the business quite a bit um
you know vaynerx
our production company which films
live videos has taken a massive hit and
lost half its revenue
and i responded by letting go
and and furloughing a lot of employees
and being upfront with them and trying
to do the best i can for them but there
was no way out
vayner speakers the speaking bureau i
lost
35 speeches that was a lot of revenue
for me
all gone we had to let go some people
but i didn't i didn't let go of my
leaders in either one of those two
companies i've just taken on those
losses
because i know they'll be tomorrow
that's a good idea that's a good insight
because you made a difference between
some of them and the others
right that's right um you know
vaynermedia
initially took a huge hit lost some
clients
had clients stop paying hurt our cash
flow we have bills to pay
so we also had to do some layoffs but
we've been very aggressive and i've been
working 15 hours a day on zoom 12 hours
a day on zoom
business developing trying to find new
clients so you know it's it's um
it's amazing um how uh
how much i enjoyed this very painful and
that's the word i would use
chapter because i was prepared for it um
we pivoted we we started doing virtual
happy hours to do business development
i started checking in on employees we
spoke to the employees we we
went through a lot and so it's been very
effective
affected our reaction has been very
effective
i promoted my general counsel mark
yardkin to the co position because he's
a
he was on his way to being there so he's
been a great partner of mine
all my so many of my leaders have
stepped up and we're a better
organization for it
cool so we are moving forward
uh to one of the subjects that you know
is very important for you attention
getting the attention so one of the
questions related to this subject
is uh what are your recommendations for
entrepreneurs and startups founders
to earn media attention because you
managed in a way to do it
so what do you recommend what
recommendations we have for them
do high risk high reward activities
that are newsworthy that are around
good ideas that are authentic um
you know by putting yourself out there
in content that is going to lead to
media attention but that depends on how
good
or charismatic or smart or creative you
are
it's hard to say to somebody be creative
right of course it's like say somebody
be a great
football player and then you'll be in
the world cup well no kidding
but you know how and the answer is you
have to practice
everybody who's watching right now and i
appreciate a lot more tweets are coming
through so it's great to see all of you
you know sander n
and tenace paul right now who just
tweeted at me
if they want attention they need to
create
a piece of content or a physical
situation but think backwards think like
a headline writer
think like a newspaper man or woman
think like an anchor on tv
for example if you sell coffee why not
make a 500
cup of coffee that you sell at your
place that's crazy
but that's also the kind of thing that
the news
outlets may pick up on and be like have
you heard there's a new cafe in
romania that's selling 500 cups of
coffee
there better be gold in that coffee you
know and and so you have to reverse
engineer
what would stop somebody so it's either
very good quality content that
over a consistent period of time i did
wine library tv for 18 months
really well with a good personality
and then somebody asked me to be on tv
for the first time every day
for 18 months so it takes time
so talkability and also thinking about
the the newspapers like like a customer
what do they need what do they need in
order to write something about me cool
uh another question related to the same
thing it's
which brand should our participant build
first
business or personal because you know we
always think it's the egg or the chicken
who's first
who's driving who's driving the things
well speaking from a one-person place
i built business first you know a lot of
people forget my story
you know from 22 to 34 for 12 years
i worked and built a very large
e-commerce and retail
business for my father it was a strategy
or it was
it was a strategy or it it's just the
natural things
there was there was no options there was
no personal brand building
sure it was 1998 right today
i think you can do both i would
personally
if some if my sister asked what she did
and she's doing it in real estate and
what i would tell everybody here
i would do both i would be building my
business and i would also be documenting
don't speak like an expert if you're
just building it i would be documenting
the journey
sharing my feelings journaling to the
world
about my experiences my learnings my
difficulties
and so um that that's what i would do so
to me i don't think it's an either or
i think that the answer is both in in
these times
so you're very active on every platform
and i want to
ask you some things about linkedin and
uh of course tiktok but first linkedin
what is the biggest mistake people make
on linkedin
underestimating it
why i don't think uh because i think
right now professionally it may be the
single most interesting platform
in social and digital and content media
it is got an enormous audience
it has i mean anybody who's watching
right now who's in b2b
if you are not taking your content
strategy on linkedin extremely
seriously you're making a massive
mistake it should be your number one
sales
channel um
it's acting like facebook five years ago
six years ago seven years ago what do i
mean by that
you create a linkedin account you post
content
and you're getting organic awareness
you post and nobody follows you a
thousand people see it
you can't do that on instagram you can't
do that on twitter
you can't do that on facebook anymore
besides tic toc
there are only two platforms right now
at scale globally
that are platforms you can sign up for
today
make a video post it and 500 people will
see it that have never heard of you
so for most people who don't have money
to amplify every piece of creative
or any piece of creative they rely on
organic reach
the problem is all the big platforms
twitter youtube all these
organic reach is very difficult because
of the saturation of content
linked in right now whether it's b2b
content or b2c content
if you're a health and wellness even
even even b2c in
linkedin correct this is why i'm excited
if you're a health and wellness
influencer putting out a piece of
content on linkedin right now would be
just interesting to see what you would
get out of it just to see what people
would see because the people on linkedin
are still human beings
of course but some of them will comment
will comment this is not facebook
go to facebook this is a more
professional area so what would
what do we do my friend my friend when i
posted
business videos for the first time in
2009 every single comment all of them
were like hey wine guy why are you
talking about business you don't know
anything about business
talk about wine true
so what about tick tock you're posting
on tick tock so you think
tick tock is a is is a platform that we
should
we should create let's say a long term
long tail
uh let's say platform for younger
generation
it's an investment it's a long-term
investment investment or it's just
a quick platform to sell or to promote
every platform is long-term investment
when it's hot
i think of tick-tock and every social
network
like a television show in the 80s
if you think back to the 80s or to the
era of television
when a network or a tv show was the
number one hit
everybody wanted to run commercials on
it right
true no brand
or company worried if that show would
still be big next year
they just knew it was big now
some shows went on to have eight years
of being big
and they ran commercials the whole time
other shows were only big for two years
for me two things that people don't
understand about tick tock number one
there's an ungodly amount of 30 40 and
50 year olds on the platform
enormous number two
i'm not worried if tic-tacs gonna be
here in a year or two
if it right now it has an ungodly amount
of attention so i will create for it
the end got it so talking about
digital campaigns uh uh
how can you maybe you can name
three strategies uh to keep a high level
of attention
in a campaign three things that are very
important in order to keep the attention
of a campaign because
we've seen a lot of campaigns that are
you know starting slow or
ending slow and you know the attention
is like energy you have to keep it
you cannot store it uh
first and foremost number one two and
three is the idea
a great campaign marketing strategy is
completely at the mercy of the creative
idea
so it's not about tactics oh it's about
tactics
but i'm very very talented at tactics
so are many people watching and many
other people if it was about tactics
all of our campaigns would work
true right sure it's when it's when the
idea
and the message and the story is good
along with to your point and i know
where the question's going
after you put out the video are you
putting out little pieces of content
for a month supporting the video to
drive to the video
did you put out content for a month
before the video to get insights
to figure out how to make the video
better um
can you get can you run the media in
places like tick-tock and linkedin where
people aren't thinking but
we know there's attention on tactics and
strategy
i'm unstoppable
but i'm at the mercy of the creative
very interesting uh and i'll take it
i'll take it a step further
to make it a little bit more about
business
what's fascinating about what i just
said and what's a very important insight
of the balance between tactics and ideas
is if you take it up a notch after you
have a great campaign
let's say you got the ideas and tactics
right
you're at the mercy of the product
i tell people all the time you know
people reach out to me
gary you're the best vaynermedia's the
best i want to work with you i said cool
before anything before i hear any other
thing out of your mouth
you understand that if i and our team
does our job well
all that we're gonna do is speed up
everybody knowing
about your product so if your product
and service
stink all i'm gonna do is you're gonna
pay me a lot of money
to speed up the world knowing that your
product stinks
of course cool
so let's go back to startups and
startups environment i think you get a
lot of
ideas and a lot of guys that are looking
for investment from you
so maybe maybe you have two or three or
four things that you that we expect
from a startup in order to invest in
this startup what are the three
checkboxes that you need to fill
in order to invest time energy
money partnership whatever
great question um first thing
that i'm going to tell everybody it's
the number one mistake that founders
make when they pitch companies
if you do not know the answer to a
question you must acknowledge it
the the number one reason i don't invest
in companies
is because i ask them a question that i
know the answer to and they give the
wrong answer
or they dance around the answer
so which one is more which more has more
penalty from you
uh going around the answer or being
straightforward
i haven't maybe a wrong answer but this
is my answer
they're both the same
[Laughter]
it means you don't know the answer and
that you didn't have the strength or the
candor
to admit it which then led to me knowing
that you don't know your business as
well as i need you to know the business
because if i know the answer
and you don't that's a problem for me
because i'm not going to be there every
day
number two what i always look for is do
i believe that human beings will do the
thing that the person is telling me
they're going to do within the next 36
months
it's a very important answer if i don't
believe that
humans will buy what the person's
putting down
in the next 36 months i can't invest
because then i'm at the mercy of too
much
time leading to bad behavior of
impatience or wasting money
which is why i didn't invest in any vr
companies in the last five years because
i don't think it's tomorrow
three the thing i need to know is that
the
entrepreneur i make i'm guessing that
the entrepreneur i'm sitting in front of
is going to be able to deal with things
like covet
is the person actually an entrepreneur
or has entrepreneurship and startups
and starting your own company become so
cool that everybody wants one
cool you know the first answer answer
that you that you gave us
it's very important for us also we have
a show that is a
franchise of shark tank in in romania so
we have a lot of questions and some of
them
don't have any answer and we asked them
you came unprepared how come they say i
don't know i
only talk i only know about my product
not about the
things that you ask me so they are very
much focused on the product
or the service and they they don't know
the answer for a lot of
business questions so that's you know
i'm glad that you that you put the first
answer right this one because it's
really important to know a lot of things
about the strategy tactics vision
uh everything around the product and
service it's not only
i mean product and service is just a big
a small part
so thank you very much for this of
course
you know product and the product is a
very very very big part
to your to your proper observation
it's just not the only part and most
engineers
and most practical operators
don't see that business is one
in the gray sure
and uh and actually i think business is
one more or less by how you treat other
human beings
first your own employees then your
customers and i think that is the big
misstep
of the of most executions that i see
so after the startup what
characteristics do you find
uh like successful characteristics of a
scalable business
how do you see in advance if a business
is scalable or not
what do you say i'm sorry one more time
because i'm uh i'm replying to
sander and with a very nice observation
uh so i apologize but i like the human
reaction what was the question my friend
uh the question was how do you see uh
the characteristics of of a scalable
business what what do you search
in order to see that or to you know to
see in advance that this business
could be scalable yeah two things
both guesses yeah unless you're looking
at data that shows that the business
went from 8
to 27 to 30 to 54 and you can see it's
on fire that's just easy that doesn't
take anybody special
but before that to see it early on that
it's scalable
i look for i do two guesses one my
belief
that coconut water or bicycle running
or form-fitting t-shirts or
red wine or or you know
seaweed cookies can and will explode
so it's me guessing and two
is the person in front of me an
entrepreneur or an operator because if
they're an operator they won't
let it grow fast enough
it's a very interesting insight if
somebody's classically business trained
they're going to be overly excel sheet
disciplined
and they won't see the moment where it's
time to pour lighter fluid
and they need to be an artist to feel
the momentum and go hard
and a lot of people are robots and
school children
not artists it is an art form to know if
something can get crazy and become crazy
quickly
in a stable way that's not just based on
raising capital
and then being underwater and then
losing your business two years later
that is what i look for in a human
interesting
so what's your opinion about about
the age that we are living now is this a
good period to start a business
or not there's never a bad time to start
a good business
why is that why is that because history
told me
okay every year every year of the last
hundred years
including world wars pandemics global
recessions
every single year substantial businesses
were born
there's never a bad time to start good
business so people that are uh you know
postponing this moment are not real
entrepreneurs right
well they might be real entrepreneurs
their personal situation might not allow
them
to jump right now and they're you know
listen i do think the more fear you can
handle
without stress is a complete indicator
on your upside as an entrepreneur or is
at least one of the indicators
at the same token i think it's dangerous
to just blanket statement
i think that some people do have
circumstances that
it would be foolish or way too high risk
too
on the flip side i do find that most
people use excuses forever to never
start it because
they actually aren't it got it
so i'm going a little bit in into an
area that you love also the shop
entailment
shopping entertainment live streaming a
combination that is new for
for on for for e-shopping uh is this the
future or
how do you see it yes i think china
social networks and soon to be
american social networks will continue
to see vertically integrated live video
content driving to business results
for someone i i think that that is real
life
stuff and i think that that is um a
hundred percent
um something that people should look at
in america we call it qvc
home shopping network i'm sure the
global audience has their versions of it
but do i believe
that if this was if i was still 23 years
old
at my daddy's liquor store would i be
doing wine library tv live on tick tock
live or
if i was in china wechat or if i was or
soon to be instagram or facebook live
with links to product and selling
product yes i believe i would be doing
that
okay so usually the entrepreneurs are
you know they fear of losing money what
can you tell them
in order to overcome this obstacle
mental uh
let's say obstacle
um if you're doing entrepreneurship for
money to buy things
you're going to eventually be unhappy
so you know it worries me when
when it's about the cars and the private
planes and the boyfriends and the
girlfriends and the spa treatments and
traveling and the money
and the product bags and shoes
and watches because it's an indication
to me that
somebody wants the you know somebody
wants the
actual things that come from
entrepreneurship
more so than that they want the game of
entrepreneurship
does that make sense sure and so when
somebody
loves the game then they really win
but when somebody's just you know doing
it
for kind of like
the stuff they always lose so
entrepreneurs that just want the money
or are scared to lose the money are
always vulnerable and i would ask them
to rethink the situation
and really assess their lives
cool because you know startups are
difficult
and a lot of people
expect the results of the
entrepreneurship but they they don't see
the rest
how important is it is for for
entrepreneur to see
uh to have a mentor or to see his work
every day and the effort that he is he's
doing
to see real efforts in the in the back
of the business
that drives success
is the quo i want to make sure i
understand the question how important is
having a mentor
yes and and and i can expand the
question
uh because i i see a lot of young people
that are you know
they they expect to have prada uh bags
and things like this
but they don't know the the effort that
the entrepreneur an entrepreneur is
doing in the back so
so how soon a young
person who wish to become an
entrepreneur
should start the mentorship program and
the shadowing
let's say shadowing more than mentorship
i i think it comes down to how you learn
you know for example i didn't do
mentoring
i you know for me the way i learn is
through
listening to the customer and so
but i think for a lot of people
mentorship was extraordinary
and the reason that they were able to
succeed so
for me so i'm trying to get some air
it's hot in here
for me um for me i think
that this is a answer that is very very
much
um personal you know
you know for me i don't think there's a
right answer to to
when or what um you know somebody might
be like me and started the first 10
years
without having mentorship direct
mentorship but have felt
over the last two three years to be in a
rut
and now they've decided to you know get
an entre to get a mentor and i think
that's right too
or the other way around you know some
people
might have outgrown their mentors
and that's okay too so you know to me
that's how i think about that so how do
you how do you
qualify your videos uh shadowing
mentoring
uh documenting a mix of them
meaning meaning the way my how do i see
my videos
for people out there yes yes context
i think of them as context i think that
you create the context and they watch
they watch how you do it
i create the content and i hope that
they're able to contextualize
the information for their real situation
and that they're able to extract some
value out of it you know i'm a unique
entrepreneur in that
i share a lot of content and for free
and so you usually have people that are
running big companies like i do
that you never see or you have a lot of
people
who share content but their business is
to sell programs
to people i'm in a very weird space
where i'm running big companies but also
putting out
an enormous amount of content for me
that is me doing two things one creating
top of the funnel awareness about who i
am which may lead to other business
opportunities in the future
and that's 50 of it and 50 of it is my
giving back to the game that i love so
much i feel like i'm
giving out a business school for the
people that can get value out of
a communicator like me because i'm not
for everybody and i understand that but
i think a lot of people have learned
more about business
through my free content than a lot of
money they've spent
in schools and programs sure i
i think we have a lot i have a last
question in business
but it's more about personal brand a lot
of them
are watching you a lot of entrepreneurs
and content content creators are
you know watching your work and they
they love the
the way that that you are doing and the
fact that you are very famous
but uh can you please tell tell us uh
the dark side of being
famous in online uh if if they need to
be prepared for something
that is really tough and difficult for a
human being to
you know to bear well look i tell a lot
of my friends you know as you probably
know and a lot of people know i don't
really share my personal life
um and that's because you know i want to
keep that
in my private soul like you you know
meanwhile i share a lot of content so i
tell people whatever you share with the
world
becomes theirs so
um you know
you know you can't put your baby in
every picture and then be mad when
somebody says something about your baby
of course right it's public that's right
so
you know i think the downside is you've
opened up
you know the ability for people to have
opinions about you and share
in your life and and that's okay
i i do that i mean every i i've opened
up the ability for anybody to say
anything they want about anything
with my with my business world
um and and i take on the ram you know it
hurts my feelings when people think i'm
i have bad intent
or i'm a huckster or you know
doing this because i just care about my
like that hurts your feelings
when you're a human being but i have to
accept that comes with it so the
downside is judgment
and how you handle judgment is
often another very big indicator on how
much you can succeed
in putting yourself out there and
building a brand
what about what about the haters how do
you manage i'm sure everyone has haters
how do you manage
the relationship with them you
how do i manage what the the
relationship with with the haters with
people that are you know crossing the
line and doing
telling nasty things about you how do
you manage this because this is
this is really difficult for a human
being to to manage this
i deal with hate um with a heavy level
of compassion sympathy
and empathy if somebody has time
to consume my content
and deploy hate
on me that's a really
not fun place for that person to be in
their headspace
i have never in my life spent time
consuming somebody
to then try to tear them down in the
comments
hmm cool we have we have a lot of
people that are commenting also on our
social media so edward is one of them
he's saying hi very uh insistent so
maybe you can wave to edward and say
hi because we are at live event and uh i
love you brad
he was very he was he was very into it i
want to
tell this to to gary so thank you very
much for doing this
so let's go a little bit to personal
life because this is more juicy let's uh
let's talk about
you know uh what people do you admire
in your personal life that's a great
question
i'm an enormous admirer of kindness
i'm an incredible admirer of someone
who's able to be the bigger person
in a disagreement uh
i'm a massive admirer of somebody who
is able to deploy work ethic to the
extreme
but not at the cost of their mental or
physical health
um that's i admire that and you know the
first two things i said
my mother is my great hero in those
things
um and very honestly i'm very
the thing i'm most proud of in the in a
very
i mean the most there's a lot of things
i'm proud of in myself there's plenty of
things that i
wish i did better but i love the fact
that i love what i do for a living
have the ability to have a ton of work
ethic because it requires that to create
big things
but if but do not go into depression or
sadness or burnout
when i need to sleep 10 hours i sleep 10
hours when i need to
focus on sports cards for a week because
it's just too much
i'm good when i need to go on vacation
and
read a book you know for two weeks then
i'm okay with that like
i don't judge myself when i'm not
hustling
that's a good one but you know at the
beginning it was just
just hustle because you you needed to
reach and to be to be here
and now you can slow down or what what
what should i should i understand i
probably can't
you know what's funny i probably work
just as much if not even slightly more
because of technology than i did when i
was a kid
um no i think i think work ethic matt
when you don't have anything work ethic
really really matters
like but again a lot of people have
taken hustle and they've converted into
a word that is a negative word
where they burn themselves out i mean
this is a marathon
and i want people to take plenty you
know like i'm looking to work for
you know 70 years and you know
my success did not come because i
hustled my success came because i was
kind to my employees and my customers
i was extremely educated and smart in
the category of wine
i put in a lot of hours educating myself
on modern communications like the
internet
email google adwords youtube when most
people didn't see it
so you know my my internet that's cool
that's a cool description of hustle it's
it's more
uh elevated it's i like it it is more
elevated and and you know to be frank
a lot of my friends and family members
and people that have worked with me
they get mad at me because i never talk
about being smart
you know it took it took a level of
talent to recognize in 1996 that
e-commerce was going to be humongous
of course it took a level of talent to
be on twitter and facebook and instagram
and all these platforms first and
hardest and best
so i i um
i am as i get older and these gray hairs
come in
i am trying to be more thoughtful in
creating all the nuances of the story
again as context there are there's
hundreds of thousands of people that
have been more financially and
even impact successful than me in
business so this is not about i'm so
cool
this is let me give you everything i
know
let me give you everything i know
because if it helps you
and you send me an email and say that i
helped your life that changes
that feels way better to me than an
extra thousand dollars
sure and you also i think you felt that
when you given information you create
space for a new one it's like
we have a finite space of
information so we have to share it in
order to receive more it's like you know
a
bucket full of of water and you ask for
more you
have to spread a little bit so uh
i i just want to ask you a
thing that will be very valuable for our
uh for our what
viewers what do you think what what will
be big in five years
because you talked about e-commerce 10
years ago so
right now garyvee make a prediction
about the future what industries or
products or services it will be really
big in five years
i think sms retail i think people buying
through sms
is going to be big i think
voice activated ai devices like alexa
and google
um people doing more things with their
voice
i think that influencer marketing humans
getting money
humans having production companies
around them putting out content on the
internet
i think fragmented ott
micro subscription content plays on top
of the internet
stream through television the long tail
of ott
those those are the things that stand
out for me cool
cool we're going back to personal but
you you you know you talked about this
and i think was it was juicy enough for
for our viewers
so um we have uh all of all of us as
entrepreneurs we have scars because we
made a lot of mistakes
do you have any regrets
you know i'm too happy to have regrets
but i will tell you that
um i
i made a lot of mistakes i
believe it or not believe it or not on
stage i can be very
aggressive and candorous but in real
life as a leader
it's taken me a long time to lead with
candor
because i always led with sweetness and
kindness and comfort and leadership and
lack of fear and i'll take care of it
so i regret not regret because i really
don't regret it
i'm excited that at this stage of my
career i'm getting better at candor and
telling my employees when they're not
doing a good job
um which is big which is big for me
because that's hard for me because and
then what was unfortunate was
because i would be painful for me when
they were under delivering and being
delusional
it led to me being passive aggressive
with them
making comments you know or surprising
them when i fired them so
that's you know i i i always want to be
the best i can be and so that's
not something i'm thrilled about i
i could have bet bigger you know i was
so right about facebook twitter
uber all these things so i could have
put bigger bets
um and would have done better that's a
micro
um in hindsight um
i innovated a lot i created a lot of
things that went on to become bigger
things and i didn't productize them i
just used them on my businesses
open cart optimization i'm doing it with
wine text right now text sms i just told
you it was going to be big in five years
it's going great for my dad's business
but i'm not building a spotify
or a shopify or a wordpress and i
probably should
um i uh
i uh and look i
i probably didn't negotiate hard enough
for the right business deal with my dad
or my brother my two partners in my life
always i always when it's personal is
difficult yeah yeah i mean look
i i you know i took my dad's business
from a three to a 60 million dollar
business from 22 to 34 years old and i
left at 34 years old and i had nothing
you know and i had to start over you
know which
you can imagine double hurts when haters
try to make pretend that my story was my
dad gave me something
you know don't listen to garyvee he
started this or his dad
he was already rich he was already rich
right it's just not it's just not the
truth as a matter of fact
i'm in a very rare very rare club
of somebody who gave to my dad not the
other way around
um uh and then my brother and i started
vaynermedia and he was 22 years old i
had already had a little bit of the
garyvee thing going on
and and yet i still started that
business 50 50 with him
so i you know i i didn't do a good job
negotiating with
my dad and brother but i'm not i'm not
regret
i don't resent them or regret it one of
the great
gifts of my life is to give and you know
so that's um
that's that's it cool we all have
challenges and you have
you've had challenges in your life but
maybe one of them
helped you to to grow tremendously do
you
do you recall one of them a big
challenge that helps you uh
become a better better person or a
better entrepreneur or
you know well i think i think the
biggest usually in
behind every challenge is it's a big
opportunity to change to grow
so how about you my father my father my
father
was a very quiet old school man
who didn't talk a lot was not a good
communicator and
and was a very rough around the edges
um immigrant and
i had to figure out from the age of 14
to the age of 34 for 20 years how to
work with him
and i think it made me an incredible
reader of people
i think it helped me understand how to
break through to people
i think one of the reasons i'm such a
convincing storyteller
and articulator i feel very in the zone
right now in this interview
i feel like people are getting a real
insight to a deeper level of me
i'm get i'm patient and calmer so i'm
able to get
more clarity out of my words and i think
a lot of those skill sets were taught
on those 40-minute drives back and forth
with my dad because i had to figure out
the angle
to change my dad's mind without getting
much
information from him other than human
reaction
which i think is which honed my
emotional intelligence
and consumer behavior skills i think i'm
one of the
really strong understanders of human
behavior on the internet
and i think a lot of that happened from
the challenge of having a
non-communicative dad
my dad didn't talk a lot and he stayed
very quiet in his own thoughts but i
needed
answers for him because i was hungry and
i was aggressive and i wanted to
build his business or him and uh you can
imagine that's frustrating and
complicated and i
and i honed those skills and i honed
them
and um and i think it makes me who i am
today i i feel you man
i i have a one last question a personal
one and uh after that after this i will
give you a few minutes to for final call
to action to to the entrepreneurs and
then i will call
uh pep to give me two minutes in order
to prepare the room because we will meet
again with uh a few hundred
entrepreneurs for uh you know for the
private conversation that we that we
arrange with you so
uh thank you very much for everything so
far uh
you know uh time is flying with you uh
i want to know how do you see that how
do you see the world in five years from
now
how how gary is seeing the world are you
pessimistic are you optimistic
and why what do you see on the at the
horizon
five is a fun number um
i think we're living through a time
right now where we're demonizing a lot
of things
i think politically both in america and
the rest of the world
were pointing fingers
and i think that we are leaning into our
differences
versus our commonalities it's creating a
lot of tension
and a lot of negativity i think
life is how you see it whatever you're
looking for you will find
and if you go on twitter right now or
facebook or instagram or wechat or weibo
or
or line or or instagram
or youtube podcasts if you're looking
for negativity
there's an unbelievable amount yeah and
you get into the loop anyway
and you get into the loop of negativity
and then you are
that's right if you look but by the way
as the counter and the finish to that
statement
if you go on all those same platforms
right now and you look for positivity
and happiness and opportunity it's
loaded
loaded sure so my hope is that five
years from now
my dream my ambition my great great
great want
is that in five years we are on the tail
end of this era
and people are exhausted of spending all
their time trying to tear each other
down and what makes us different
and we've started the next wave of
leaning into each other
and building back up and i think through
that we will see innovation
creativity joy and happiness that's how
i see it
i i was leaving space for a call to
action but i think i love this better
because it's
it's a it's a message of love and and
positivity so listen
listen listen listen we've got four more
minutes and i'll go to call of action
let me make this
because because to your to your point i
went very macro let me go micro
go ahead if you were watching if you
were watching this right now and you
have not invested
the mental the financial
the effort to build an infrastructure
that allows you to create
content every single day across as many
platforms as possible at without burning
yourself out and wasting all your money
if you've not found a sustainable mental
and financial framework
to produce content every single day on
the internet you are making one of the
great
missteps of your professional and
personal careers
and i highly recommend you get serious
about content on the internet
because it is an absolute leverage point
that is controllable by you
to change the outcome of your
opportunities
and your possibilities and the financial
impact on every business you're
associated with
gary my friend always a pleasure to talk
to you you are an inspiration for us and
thank you very much for all your time we
will see you in five minutes
in the private room with the rest of the
world changers thank you very much
pep i think from now you can take over
thank you very much christian thank you
gary it's uh you say it's a pleasure to
talk to gary it's always a pleasure to
watch you guys talk that for me is a
thrill
i see that that sounds a little creepier
than i intended but uh but it was really
a fantastic conversation so thank you
both hey everybody on youtube first of
all thank you so much so humbled for
your time
i don't want to watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from
feel free to check it out